هنا الشرق مكان لا يهدا يشتعل سياسيا يوما
بعد اخر هنا خير مثال لما يمر به السودان
من تشد وانشقاق
تعصفه بمكونات الشرق ومجالسها وقبائليها
فتعددت المسميات والتحالفات وتشتت المواقف
هنا التهديد والوعيد بان الانفصال خيار
حاضر ان لم تتم الاستجابه للمطالب
انهم هم
حاجات السوداني
يستوردوا عبر الموانئ ما في مشكله مقابل
ذلك
اقل من 24 ساعه لتنظيميه من شرق السودان
يعلنون فيها موقفهم من الراهن السياسي
اللافت ان المجلس الاعلى لنظارات البيجو
والمواقعين على اتفاقيه جوبا كانوا حتى
وقت قريب هما يعبرون عن مواطن الشرق
السودان قبل ان ينقسم جميعهم ويتناثر الى
مجموعه عديده حزب المؤتمر
في العام 94,900 والذي استمر 14 عام
نطالب
ونتمسك بتنفيذ الكامل لهذا الاتفاق
القديمه والجديده وكذلك الادارات الاهليه
والموقعين على اتفاق جوبا وضح الصراع بين
المؤيدين للاتفاق الايطالي والمعارضين له
وبارزت مفارقه جديده انه لا خلاف بينه في
الاهداف والمقاصد المتمثله بتنفيذ مخرجات
مؤتمر
الذي يتحدث باسم اهل الشرق
نحن لا نلتفت الى الاصوات العاليه
والتي نعتبرها الان لا تعبر عن كل شر
السودان
اعلنت حمل السلاح في وجه السلطه واغلقت
الميناء لمده يوم كما برز تقارب بين
مكونات من الشرق مع تحالفات العسكريه
وسياسيه المتعدده وهو ما يشير الى ان قضيه
الشرق باتت من اكثر القضايا المعقده التي
تواجهها الفتره الانتقاليه لين يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم